the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your
scale
how are you guys doing Joe Rogan has
recently come out on the Palestine issue
and said the following let's take a look
hey I want to know what was what she was
fired for cuz was it criticism of Israel
was it I mean did she show that Edward
Snowden video that he put up on Twitter
that shows them drone bombing those kids
that are those men I should say unarmed
people that were walking towards the
rubble that clearly weren't causing any
danger anybody bomb them yeah no it's
your duty it's just like for Biden or
whoever you like you're supposed to
cover up for them because the whole
thing is like they're always saying
they're only targeting Hamas and
everybody else is a casualty well if
those guys are just unarmed civilians
and they're walking alone that's what
they appear to be Dr in and you just
blast them from the sky with robots this
is the tragedy of War yeah this is
insane and no one knows what to think
now because if you can't talk about that
if you can't say that's real then you're
saying that genocide is okay as long as
we're doing it and that's what we're
saying and if you're saying that from a
perspective of someone who literally
went through the Holocaust or your your
people your tribe went through the
[__] Holocaust and now you're willing
to do it I hope the irony is not lost on
you it's so nuts it's so hard to imagine
that someone where a c a culture like a
country was like officially founded in
what 47 48 48 okay officially founded so
that's so recent and you and you guys
are willing to do what was done to you
that led you to believe that you needed
to start your own country you're willing
to do that at least on a small scale in
Gaza like there's nothing left if you
see the video now I must say this is
something to be commended this is
something that we respect as the Muslim
Community as the pro Palestinian
activists as humans who care about other
humans we must say we respect this Brave
and Gallant step from Joe Rogan
despite the consternation or the insult
that some people as we will know in uh
America or other parts of the world will
have to his comments he didn't care he
came out and said them anyway this is in
fact moral courage however one must ask
the question if this is in fact a mini
Holocaust or is in fact A Min genocide
as you claim Joe Rogan then what are we
going to do about it you and I have big
platforms you much more so than I and do
we not the question is how have a moral
responsibility to hold to
account those Pro Zionist people who are
still calling for the killing of women
and children on mass in order to achieve
some Phantom political objective where
there is no endgame in place for the
Israeli Defense Forces who are in fact
the Israeli occupation forces are we not
now if we are witnessing as you claim as
we agree a mini Holocaust of some
sorts going to make the
step and
promote or bring attention or challenge
those
antagonists who are attacking Humanity
with this
heinous crime against Humanity in Gaza
and this is the
question you're right Joe Rogan and you
not are you are not just right but you
are on the right side of History
hopefully but let that be the first step
you take that we take together to bigger
and better
things the prophet Muhammad s wasam told
us that when the son of Adam dies all of
his Good Deeds are interrupted they are
finished except for three
things a continuous charity and a
beneficial knowledge and also a a
righteous offspring that makes Dua for
him your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you will
have on your scale so give generously
and Allah will give you even
[Music]
more